so by far my favorite of the various
traditional answers to the Fermi paradox
is the cloaking one that essentially
sure okay so plenty of civilizations may
get to the point where they [ __ ]
themselves laughing but the fact is also
there are various civilizations that get
to the point of figuring out how not to
blow themselves up but they also
recognize that some other civilizations
may be not very peaceful and may be
willing to go and mess people up right
and call a nice force for example yeah
that's right
and the best way not to be colonized
with force it's not to be noticed
now of course today we're aware that we
are pumping out you know radio waves
stuff this rather rather indicative of
our intelligence rather fast into it's
not about having radio yeah you know at
the moment but it's not obvious that we
would necessarily need to be doing that
we could quite possibly get to a
situation where we could do everything
we wanted to do down here and the radio
words we're not getting out and if that
were true we might feel that we were
safer from other civilizations
so one perfectly good explanation for
the Fermi paradox is that there are
better civilizations civilizations out
there that have survived perfectly well
for a nice long time but they don't want
anyone to know that they exist